the denial of Truth was a big mover for
me in in changing my my viewpoint on a
lot of different subjects and it's also
the fact that
there's so much hypocrisy in that
statement of you can be whoever you want
to be when you really get down to the
root of how they are implementing this
in their own lives if you look into
leftism and you look into it deeply and
especially identity politics you will
find that there is no space to be
whoever it is that you want to be there
is no space to think whatever it is that
you want to think and in fact they are
hell-bent on pushing people into boxes I
felt no greater racism than going on the
internet and saying I am a conservative
it was unbelievable how quickly people
jumped to me and said well you're a
female You couldn't possibly be a
conservative you're half black You
couldn't possibly be conservative this
is the box that is created for those
identity markers and we must Jam you
into that box and if you do not fit you
are alienated you are no longer a part
of the club so as much as they say
everybody's special and unique and they
can be whoever they want to be they
don't think that at all and they think
there's no greater
I guess social experiment to prove that
that is the case then what's happening
right now with gender if you look at
somebody like Dylan Mulvaney who came up
in that Matt Walsh video who we've both
been talking about quite a bit Dylan
Mulvaney is a feminine man
it's as simple and plain as that but
because he's expressed himself femininly
they say well you must now shove
yourself into the box that is Womanhood
and we must now claim you as a woman we
must call you she and her and this is
the box that you now fit in I'm pretty
sure you're telling us quite happy to be
shoved in that box I think Dylan is
desperate to get in that box he really
is I think he's proven that time and
time again but the the issue still
stands there's no no I get who you are
of course no I get your point completely
and
um you know it's the denial the whole I
mean if you're if you're a fan of Thomas
old the whole idea of nature he's
written extensively about how the left
and the right see that very differently
um and I'm curious with you living in La
do you have any friends
I do
I have managed to find friends uh I've
I've got some some brilliant friends
some of whom I've met through prageru
others who I've met just through moving
to the city met my boyfriend here in La
somehow I just think I've been I've been
very lucky
no it's funny the reason I ask is a very
good friend of ours called Bridge of
fantasy who you probably have heard of
yeah
um when we traveled around America last
year we did a whole trip and we went to
uh we went to Virginia and Washington
and New York in a bunch of places and
everywhere we went there's gigantic
American flags all over the place loads
of houses have them outside and then we
got to Bridget's house and she had this
like tiny little American flag in the
corner of a little bit of a door and I
went that's California patriotism you
have a flag but it is about this big in
a corner because you can't you can't
have the big one no yeah you're 100
right most of the people who I meet who
watch my content here in La I I can see
them because they kind of walk up to me
and they whisper but they that they like
what I have to say or that they follow
me on Instagram you can't say anything
too loud you have a lot of quiet friends
here in Los Angeles
but surely Amela is going to come to a
point with like we're we're in San
Francisco where you look around and you
go
this can't carry on this is this is
insanity
I like to think that's gonna happen I I
don't know I really don't know it's
crazy to watch as things just
deteriorate and people I don't know if
they're not making the connection
between what they're voting for and
what's happening in their city or if
they just simply cannot bring themselves
to you know tick The Ballot Box of
somebody who they they feel they
fundamentally disagree with I don't know
that it's going to change and all the
conversations that I have with people
who are supporting the stuff that's
happening in La it's kind of like they
just turn a blind eye to to the
destruction and
you would think like Yuri besmanov says
you you don't really recognize it until
the military boot kicks you in the ass
the military boot is kicking them in the
ass here and they're not making the
connection I I don't know I don't know
how long you you should be the person
who has the answer to this because I
guess the question would be four years
ago if someone has said to you look
around you know there's drug drug
addicts who are not getting the help
they need sleeping on the streets being
sexually assaulted spreading disease to
each other and the rest of the pop like
all of that yeah surely I'm only you're
against that as a woke activist surely
you want those people to be better right
so so what would your answer have been
I think I would have found a way to
blame it on the people who I disagree
with
I would have managed I really think I
would have managed I was really good at
just running my mouth and twisting words
and I think that's exactly what I
probably would have spun it and said you
know the income disparities created by
conservatives and we need to tax the
rich and and that's what's going to help
these people who are impoverished and
who are you know doing drugs on the
street I would have found a way knowing
myself
foreign